ezekiel yo do you know how hard is it to
find a gpu these days
like goddamn scalpels man if only we
have a brand new graphic card that's
affordable and powerful that we all
deserve yeah thank god something for you
man
catch
[Music]
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
head shots with the logitech g pro x
super light mouse the lightweight
wireless mouse combines excellent
performance with a classy no frills look
designed with pros and engine it to win
it offers crisp and responsive clicks
the smooth operator even allows you to
swap out the magnetic dongle storage
compartment for greater gliding ease
check out all of its other features over
at logitechg.com
what's up guys it's jung your resident
unboxer gate culture today we have with
us the amd radeon rx 6600 xt gpu
rog strix version
we will be running some tests to see how
it can perform and whether it's really
built
to outperform the rtx 3060
all right let's get started
so if you're wondering
why amd would push out 1080p gpu
optimized gpu well the truth is not
everyone rocks a 4k setup and in fact
majority of the consumers out there
still has a 1080p setup just like myself
so here we go
the amd
6600 xt gpu
looking slick
okay let's
see how we can do this without
damaging the card
oops
a couple of
brochures over here and then
cable strap
thanks to the
gpu market right now
most of us are stuck at our 1060 or 2060
rtx right and it's been forever since we
were able to upgrade our laptop
so hopefully
the
6600xt will be the lifesaver
for all 1080p gamers out there
look at this
beautiful
magnificent
you can see the rog brand right here
well
also at the side we can tell that it's
uh using an 8-pin
8 pin block here and then
amount of display parts over here we
have
three display ports and one hdmi port
and i believe this is hdmi 2.1
so that's pretty dope and the fans are
awesome
all right let's check out the back
there's a really nice gun metal finish
here and it even spots the rog logo and
design really sleek
so we don't want to go too much into
specifications but for starters the gpu
runs on amd's are the na2 architecture
and it has 8gb
memory
so
it's pretty impressive and it supports
directx 12 pcie 4.0 and you might be
surprised it draws a 160 watt power
meaning you can actually
stuff
this
gpu into a 500 watt psu entire setup so
that's really really impressive what amd
radeon has done here and it supports
plenty of amd uh features uh radeon
boost anti-lag fidelity fx so
without talking too much man we're just
gonna get right to it put this into our
machine and then we'll see how it runs
all right so what we have here is
aftershocks trixo which rocks an rtx 30
70. but for today we will be replacing
it with the 6600 xt
so let's do
the whole
upgrade
or downgrade
you do here is remove the
pcie
right
one last screw
all right here we go right so in terms
of size and appearance the build looks
pretty much the same what we have here
is the zotek giving 3070 and then over
here is the asus rog streaks
xt
all right power connector in displayport
in we're ready to rock this
gpu
look at that
rgb
all right so we've finally installed the
rx 6600 xt
onto our aftershock trixo and we will be
running the new back for blood beta
version of the game to check out how it
performs
as you can tell once we've installed the
amd drivers there's a software by md
called gpu tweak 2 which has a lot of
optimization that you can see
over here we have gpu clock memory clock
fan speed gpu temperature it's all ready
for you to check it out
so on the top left corner of the screen
you'll be able to see the fps the gpu
clock speed and temperature of the
graphic card so we're going to give the
game a go
see how it fares out
in this new
bag for blood zombie killing
so far it's stable at
70
to 80 fps which is
amazing in case you guys didn't know
while it's 1080p optimized we are
actually playing the game at 4k while
the graphic card is 1080p optimized amd
actually has this feature called
fidelity fx which allows you to maintain
the frame rate even if you are playing
it at 4k resolution so yes we're
actually playing the game at 4k
and it's still stable at 70fps which is
really impressive
you can tell on the gpu clock speed on
the top left corner of the screen it's
at about 2.5 k generally the fps is
stable around 60 to 70 so
it's really looking good
at high settings and on 4k
all right guys previously we were
running on
4k at high settings but now we've
decided to go 1080p
maximum settings epic and we're gonna
see how
much is the difference
let's get into the game and let's meet
some zombies
right
from the get-go you can tell we are
hitting 160 fps that's almost that's two
times the fps
or you're running on 4k
so the 6600 xd potentially can be
the next household graphic card if they
do
have enough stocks for all of us
we do hope it's not going to be another
nvidia problem
so
let's pray that there are enough plenty
of 6600
xt in the market
because every gamer deserves deserves
their upgrade
we're hitting 180 fps 190 fps
and even 220 fps
that's three times the fps of 4k
resolution
a lot of you guys must be wondering why
amd wants to push a 1080p
optimized graphic card instead of 4k
while true be told the market
to be honest uh has a higher margin of
people running on 1080p instead of 4k
like myself i'm running on a 24 inch
monitor and 1080p for years and it has
it's been good enough and the only
problem is that my graphic card is still
an o1 and i've been looking for an
upgrade since a long time ago and the
market just
the market prices are just crazy so back
for blood might not be everybody's cup
of tea so we're going to load up
fortnite and see how it performs
all right so now we've loaded into
fortnite at 1080p resolution and then
running at epic settings we're now
hovering at about 100 fps but we do get
some frame drops here and there it might
be because the game is not optimized for
for the gpu yet
since it's still new
but hopefully
you might be able to see some changes
in the future
i do see some enemies over here
i'm not very good at this game as you
can tell
this guy has a laser holy [ __ ] i'm
pretty much dead
i can't test this game i die every five
seconds when i'm in it running war zone
on 1080p with a few customized settings
but majority are not high and we have
the fps counted on the top left
of the game and you can
see we are hovering at about 100 fps
looking good so far
well we are actually very far away from
our friends unfortunately
so far so good we're hovering at 90 fps
and
occasionally we do see some frame drops
but
not a huge problem
so as you guys can see
at about
370 us dollars the graphic card is
really outperforming itself we can run
even at 4k even though it's a 1080p
optimized graphic card at 4k we're still
getting 100 fps 80fps you can see from
the textures the shaders the fps and
it's stable it's great and take note
that we got an early release of the gpu
kit so the graphic drivers are still in
its early stages so we are expecting a
lot more updates so all these frame
drops that they are saying like just
because of the drivers it's not
optimized yet so there is a huge
potential we are seeing with the rx 6600
xt and we really have high hopes for
this one so the radeon rx 6600 xc will
be going on sale for about
379 usd so hopefully gamers like you and
i will be able to get this graphic card
at that price instead of over a thousand
dollars thanks to all those
scouters so that wraps up the whole
video we're glad you stick around let us
know down in the comment section below
whether you think this is the 30-60 kilo
and whether if you're gonna get one for
yourself
thank you for watching don't forget to
like the video subscribe to the channel
this is jung see you in the next one
[Music]